bang bang what's going on guys hope you
guys are really excited about this
interview i really enjoyed it i think
you will as well but before we get into
that make sure that you
like this video so that more people on
youtube can find it make sure you're
subscribed to the channel
and don't forget that blockfi is the
sponsor today they've got three products
you can buy and sell crypto on their
crypto exchange you can deposit crypto
and earn up to 8.6
apy in an interest bearing account or
you can deposit crypto and take out a us
dollar loan against your crypto
collateral
you can use the description right here
or you can go to blockfi.com
to learn more all right let's get in
this episode i hope you guys enjoy this
one
all right guys bang bang i've got scott
here with me thank you so much for
coming back sir
thanks for having me absolutely let's
just jump right into the
topic of the day uh nfts seem to
uh be absolutely taking the world by
storm but
uh i want to talk about everything from
the art
investor seat i think there's been a lot
of conversation from the
artists and how the artists can make
more money and how great this is for
artists but
uh obviously there's another side of the
market in the art investor and so
let's maybe start at the top with just
the macro argument for like why people
should be looking at
art in general you know whether it's
physical art or digital art
what is your kind of thought process um
around that
argument i mean we we tell investors to
think about this asset classes it's one
of the oldest asset classes sotheby's
and christie's have been around 250
years
but historically it's only been limited
to the ultra wealthy so a lot of these
paintings sell for between
a million dollars and 100 million
dollars so it really hasn't been that
accessible
masterworks is the first company to
really securitize a painting sell shares
in a painting so people could actually
invest in them
um but if you look at the investment
characteristics i mean contemporary
post-world war ii
has outperformed the s p um it's an
uncorrelated asset class meaning that
it's
it's a great tool to diversify a
portfolio so we think art has a role in
almost any investor's portfolio so
historically it just it just hasn't been
possible
yeah and so when you start to dig in
let's start with the the kind of
traditional art market
i talked a little bit about the
outperformance of the stock market
um how does that market look uh
including the securitizations that you
guys are doing today
are there limitations uh by country
by kind of wealth status accreditation
just what does that look like at the
moment i mean most investment grade
paintings
are are in excess of probably a million
dollars in purchase price right so that
so qualitatively that the way to think
about the art market on a global basis
is it's really a market where where you
have ultra wealthy people
living around the world trading one to
100 million dollar paintings with each
other
and that that is the 60 billion dollars
a year that is the transaction volume in
the art market now
um so obviously up until masterworks
there really hasn't been a way to
invest in these paintings um but but we
see that changing and i know we're gonna
talk about nfts but i think that's
another exciting
part of the art market yeah and so today
uh through something like masterworks uh
basically anyone with um you know 100
bucks
25 000 whatever it is they can come in
and they can actually participate in
these traditional pieces
and really your guy's goal is to not
only get
access uh up and kind of reduce friction
but also too
i know that you guys had this banksy
piece that you sold and there was a
pretty nice return there just walk
through maybe like that as an example as
to how masters works itself works
yeah so basically we we go out we buy we
buy a great painting and
in that case a banksy painting i think
the title of that painting was uh was
mona lisa
we we raise capital so we sell shares uh
to fund the the purchase of that
painting
and then after we sell the painting
which in that case was very fast it was
roughly uh
i think one year later we distribute
proceeds to
to investors so in that case we sold the
painting quickly i think it was a 37
return out of fees that was a great
outcome for investors
you know generally we tell people to
think about about investing in art as a
long-term hold
um seven years ten years uh really takes
a takes a while to generate returns
but we also have secondary markets for
people about trading shares and great
paintings so that's
that's alternative for people that can't
can't wait the full time
for sure and what are you seeing in the
traditional art market around prices
given the macro environment kind of all
the quantitative easing are prices going
up as more and more people look for
store value assets
i mean it's a it's a it's a great
question so we i mean historically
we've always talked about ours and asset
classes just an outperforming asset
class like it in general again for art
created after world war ii
uh it's it's outperformed the s p by i
think 150
from 1995 through through 2020 so it's
this really interesting asset class
regardless i think today we have a lot
of people who are just saying hey
governments around the world are
printing money we think inflation is
going to happen
uh we're interested in real assets and
we're interested in art specifically
so we're seeing a lot of a lot of
interest and we actually did a uh
we we co-published a report with city i
think in december of
2020 where city analyzed the the
correlation between
real interest rates and art prices and
and not surprisingly as interest rates
go down you see our prices go up
so it you know it's a conversation that
we have with investors every single day
there's there's tons of uh
tons of interest and art as a uh is an
inflation hedge for lack of a better
term
right now i am uh i am not going to be
surprised if you told me there was a big
overlap between people who believe their
macro economists and
art investors that are uh are
speculating
um let's talk about nfts uh obviously
everyone uh
seems to have woken up to this uh
whether it was beeples kind of you know
69 million dollar sale at christie's
uh now there's this artist packed at uh
sotheby's
um and then obviously all of the volume
that's going through some of these other
exchanges that are kind of digital
native
what's your take on you know what's
happening uh what questions do you have
what uh concerns or or what are you
excited about yeah i mean look we
i think we've gone through this whole
process of that everyone's gone through
which is like what is going on
to to kind of trying to rationalize it
in our own head
you know when the people thing first
happened to be totally transparent i
mean i
i i was having conversations with lots
of friends where i thought it was just
this
price fixing thing right like someone
was pretending to buy
this digital work of art for 70 million
dollars you know people is actually
being paid 69.9 million in a back room
uh to to try to you know create this
market for digital art
but after talking to christie's and the
people who worked there it seems like
that definitely wasn't the case i think
there were more than 30 bidders
uh registered on that work none of them
were known at the auction house prior to
the auction
um it seemed you know you saw the videos
of him
uh watching the sale like it definitely
seems like that was
a real transaction and it seems like
like digital art and nfts are
um are here at least for for the for the
short term
um so we you know we find it really
interesting from
from a lot of different ways like one of
the things that our investors ask us a
lot is
hey we're really interested in this blue
chip segment of the market which
outperforms the s p
has low loss rates you know that's a
that's a great um
allocation for a portfolio but how do we
get access to stuff that's more
speculative
and i think this is an interesting way
for investors to speculate in the art
market
which hasn't frankly been been available
before right like there's never been a
segment of the art market that you can
make returns like like you've seen with
within fts i mean i think that also
comes with a lot of risk and i
you know i don't know how to think about
these prices and everything right now
but uh
but it's definitely a the most
speculative segment of the of the art
market right now
you talked a little bit about like the
people who were registered for the
christie's auction
almost all if not all of them were
unknown to the auction house and so
do you look at this as basically this
isn't so much
uh the art market you know is evolving
this is literally just
net growth to art in general and this
kind of digital natives both the
platforms the artists and the art
investors
yeah with one exception so we we do know
i mean
i know of two very well-known artists
right now who
who um you know i can't say their names
but they're working on nfts
so there's there's artists themselves
have clearly woken up to
to to what's what's going on um i think
collectors are still divided right like
the people that are
investing in or buying nfts are not the
same people they're investing in are
buying
blue chip arts i think those are two two
different universes maybe those venn
diagrams overlap at some point
um but but right now they're pretty
distinct yeah
and so when you start to look at this uh
i know that there's still
kind of a moving target right you know
or do these prices make sense
uh what are the use cases but when you
look at it maybe what's like the
rationalization you're telling yourself
right so if i had to say hey be the nft
bull uh how do you think about it and
what do you say
to uh people who are skeptical
yeah so i think this is a very hard
question um
and you know if if we go back to uh
to basic fundamentals of you know how
markets are created and how markets
are sustained all markets have to have
some sort of framework in which they
they operate i was actually having this
conversation with our general counsel
earlier
and you know the the the art market
there's there's a clear understanding
between institutions and collectors
around what you know what's important
what's historically significant which
artists did what things first
um you know and they sort of have these
places in history what we refer to as
cultural significance
and there's a correlation between
cultural significance and price
and many of these artists also are you
know they're deceased or they've been
painting for
for decades and you have this long track
record of representation between
galleries and prices at auction et
cetera there's
there's this entire framework of what
you can establish price um
i think for me the question is with with
the people sale in particular
you know is what happened culturally
significant
and i think you can you can argue that
in different ways um
and and is that is that is that pressing
up for the artist and for future prices
of the artist
um you know we we see this with lots of
artists right there's tons of artists
that that we see in the art market all
the time that go from
very unknown artists to having i
wouldn't say a sense
a 70 million dollar sale but maybe a a
one million dollar sale
and then everyone's asking is this now a
million dollar artist
um so that you know that that's that's
not uncommon i just think the magnitude
of the 70 million dollars is what is
what really shocked
everyone and so in that uh kind of
historical example where there is that
one million dollar sale and then people
start asking
is this a million dollar artist how do
you normally think through that right
like
are there certain frameworks uh or data
points that you look at
to kind of determine uh is this a kind
of outlier sale or has the artist
actually
um you know increase the value if you
will of of all their pieces
yeah it's an excellent question so if
you if you look at artists in the
secondary marketing the secondary market
is really
you think of the art market divided into
two different segments primary market
which is
where artists are painting new paintings
and selling them through galleries and
the money goes back to the artist
in the secondary market where paintings
are resold over time between between
multiple collectors
generally in the secondary market most
of these artists have long track records
so you're analyzing similar paintings
that have sold historically
how prices have increased over time and
with sort of certain artists like like
boss cap for example
boss cats prices shockingly have gone up
roughly
18 a year for almost 20 years right it's
just a very predictable market that that
continues to increase
with artists that that don't have that
track record usually what you're asking
yourself
is how culturally significant is that
artist and and i would say there's not a
clear definition of cultural
significance cultural significance to us
means three different things one who
who who is that artist exhibited with
like have they been associated with
other great artists
two what institutions collect that
artist what museums collect that artist
and then three how global is the demand
for that artist um
you know but it's hard to to apply that
definition of cultural significance to
what we're seeing in the eft space
yeah if you had to make a guess as to
how the cultural significance can be
applied like that filter that
perspective
where would you start with the nfts is
it just trying to figure out like who
owns
uh this artist who's promoted them what
podcasts have they done like
just how would you try to figure that
out yeah i mean i think
i guess that's right i mean i think i
think you you would almost look at
like google trend data right like what
what's what's the what's the um the
share of voice for a particular artist
in kind of the digital ecosystem how is
that share increasing or decreasing
um the people example is is somewhat
unique and that's that's really almost
the first
very well known example of an nft sale
right so
that in itself kind of has cultural
significance um
i think does have cultural significance
um but yeah i think
i think since since this art is digital
and really all the transactions
are digital you sort of have to redefine
what what is cultural significance
yeah and it also feels like in the in
the traditional world a lot of the
data points that you described uh in
terms of uh where they've been exhibited
what institutions are collecting
um that all seems to be very kind of
analog world right which would make
sense for traditional art and kind of
the analog world
before we started we were talking about
uh what some folks are doing in the nft
space if they're trying to buy digital
art and then they're going to
essentially
display it in these digital worlds these
digital museums or
or whatever and so uh while that is not
prevalent today if that does become
prevalent it's almost a digital
recreation of a lot of the same
kind of data points if you will right in
terms of uh the the institutions or the
digital museums that are collecting may
become a
signal as well yeah i think i think
that's really fascinating and we i mean
we're thinking through the same things
right like what are the use cases for
nfts and you mentioned one which is
digital museums which i hadn't heard of
that one i think that's i think that's
super interesting
the other is just you know how do you
have devices actually display nfts and
homes so people can
you know outside of a laptop kind of
consume the art
you know the other thing that i've
wondered a lot about is how do artist
copyrights work with with nfts or do
they work with nfts
um i think that's really interesting
right like the the idea that
maybe anyone could consume an nft if
there is a fee
um is you know is there some some sort
of like brokering or sale of a copyright
of an nft
to to a marketplace of buyers um i think
that's really interesting as well
so it's super early days i mean we're
interested in it
uh it's very hard to tell where where it
goes from here
um but it does seem like it could be a
new segment of the art market that
people really haven't
haven't thought that much about and when
you think about copyright unpack that a
little bit more in terms of how you
think about copyrights in
the legacy art market and then what
you're thinking about in this
kind of digital art market yeah so many
people don't
don't realize this but if we if we buy a
painting at masterworks let's say we buy
a 25 million dollar basket
we don't actually own the copyright to
that painting that's owned by the artist
foundation
so independent of ownership the
copyright is something that's
that's separate and distinct so i you
know i
how copyrights have been licensed
historically and how that whole industry
works is pretty pretty antiquated
most most people that own copyrights
they basically generate revenue was they
you know they find people that are
violating the copyrights they
hire an attorney to go after the person
they negotiate they settle
um and that's that's how they make money
um it seems like to me there could be
could be some interesting you know
correlation between nfts and
copyrights here that could make more
sense yeah
and it almost feels like in some weird
way one of the reasons
why artists are so excited about nfts it
appears is because
they essentially can code into the
tokens that they'll get a
uh a royalty stream right kind of a 10
or 20 percent
uh on each future sale of their piece
and so copyright may be kind of
intertwined in that in some way
maybe it's a little different uh than it
is in the traditional market but it's a
way for them to at least monetize
uh much better the secondary market than
they have uh as they weigh today
yeah yeah i think that's right the you
know the other thing that that we've
just been thinking a lot about relative
to nfts is this
and i guess it's almost you know
theoretical just this concept of
scarcity
so we you know we we fundamentally know
that in the art market
one of the things that drives returns is
scarcity and the example that i always
always like to use with people is
jackson pollock so
you know pollock during his lifetime
painted all these drip paintings many of
which are 100 million
paintings today but throughout history
after he died
all of those paintings were essentially
donated to institutions except for what
i think are 21 paintings now
so out of those 21 there's only a couple
left that are great paintings most are
i wouldn't say bad examples but b or c
examples but the b or c
examples are selling for 20 million
dollars 30 million 40 million dollars
because if you want a jackson pollock
drip painting that's that's all that's
left
so i do think what what's happened here
is digital art combined with blockchain
has created this element of scarcity
which is is really interesting and
historically that's that's what's driven
our prices as well yeah and
i i guess the big piece that people
don't understand also about the
traditional art market
is uh kind of the appraisal process uh
or what i'll call the the infrastructure
around ours most people think of a
market it's just there's the artist
there's the investor the buyer
uh and that's pretty much it maybe just
touch on a little bit you know how you
guys leverage some of that
infrastructure the appraisals
um and then how with any thoughts around
you know how that translates into
the digital art market yeah it's a good
it's a good question
um so that the easiest way that i tell
people to think about how
artwork is valued is to think about real
estate which most people are familiar
with so if you
buy a house you generally get an
appraisal before you get a mortgage on a
house so art art is the exact same you
go to
major appraisal firms that are praised
paintings and they praise paintings
because
for most of these great artists there's
similar paintings that are selling
reasonably frequently call it at least
once a year and they can kind of look at
the trends and those prices of similar
paintings over time and
and arrive at a value um
you know with with the within fts i
don't know how that works right because
you have such a short time period there
really isn't isn't
a history of comparables to um uh
to value something but the thing that is
interesting i think that's most
interesting to me about the people sale
was the number of bidders right because
you have two bidders on a painting that
goes to 70 million dollars you can say
ah
there's two people that are crazy you
know here you
you had 30 people and that i mean 30
bidders on anything in the art world is
unheard of
right you don't have 30 bidders on a 25
million dollar bus yeah right like
you might have six bidders if it's a if
it's a really great example there's a
lot of demand for painting but you never
you never have 30.
so i mean the depth of bidding for that
for that
that work in general is is super
interesting and does indicate that
there's there's
real value there at least at a minimum
to those 30 people
yeah and when you think about that uh i
don't want to ask you to speculate too
much but just
why do you think it brought so many more
people than you know
kind of traditionally it would is it
just it's the first one and so naturally
people all want to kind of be a part of
it or some other reason
i think it's the i think it's the yeah
the first mover dynamic
you know i mean you know i guess i guess
the so the the optimist would say it's a
first mover dynamic
the cynic would say whoever whoever
bought the work
owns 100 other works by people and you
know he just marked the market for all
all of the other works that he owns um
could be both who you know who knows
yeah i'm very very interested to see
what the people pieces start to do in
the secondary market now
uh given such a high price point right
do they actually materially move up or
or not um when you think about
masterworks in the business today
uh obviously there is a ton of interest
uh that has kind of increased because of
the macro environment and asset
inflation
um and the one and the desire to use
that sort of value through art
uh are you also seeing or feeling any
kind of increase in just traditional art
because of nfts like almost like a
streisand effect
where people are talking more and more
about art in general so it's uh also
bleeding into the traditional market
yeah i mean you know it's interesting i
mean we our membership team has hundreds
of calls a day with
with investors who are interested in
masterworks and i mean almost all of
those calls now are
you know have some some nft question or
comment
i think it's funny like to me it's
amusing because like the person asking
the question doesn't really know what
they're talking about
the person on our membership team
doesn't really know what they're talking
about so it's kind of like
you know the game of telephone you play
when you're a child where like people
just start saying things and it doesn't
really mean anything in the end
um but but definitely it's generated a
huge amount of interest in art and
investing in art
yeah and then uh we've talked a lot
about traditional art and i think for
most of us we've been kind of referring
to physical paintings or
or other types of art um what about
sculptures you've got a great piece
there
kind of over your head but um how do you
think that is affected
does that happen a lot of the same
things that you see with paintings um
or any uh specific differences that are
worth calling out
you know so so generally speaking at
least in in a traditional art sense the
the most investable segment of our from
a medium perspective are
our paintings um if an artist is a
sculptor meaning if their main medium is
sculpture
then then generally sculpture
appreciates similarly similarly if
they're an important artist like this is
an artist named
john chamberlain who is the first artist
sort of in mid century america to use
reuse found objects in a sculptural form
um but you know mostly we tell investors
to think about paintings
generally drawings and prints don't
appreciate at the same rate as paintings
and again a lot of that just comes back
to scarcity you know you think about an
artist like picasso i use this this
state of law where a lot of people will
say
uh you know i own a picasso i have a
picasso picasso created 60 000 objects
in his lifetime
you know there's there's a whole bunch
of bad picasso out there
there's there's a very narrow amount of
of good picasso which is
super rare and continues to appreciate
really rapidly um but there's there's a
lot that's just
that's just not as important how do
people determine what's good and bad
uh in terms of picasa right because i
think people who are unfamiliar with the
art market would say well isn't it all
picasso right like
if he's such a genius uh this shouldn't
it all be great is it the way it looks
is it
uh some other sort of hierarchical
framework people have applied is it the
appraisers
how does that get determined yeah for an
artist like picasso it's really
it goes back to this cultural
significance comment right like how is
art history determined
what portion of his work is most
impactful most significant
and and you know what is least impactful
or least significant
and any artist has you know they have
true masterpieces because of guernica
for example
you know that he spent years painting
the painting um that that was one of his
masterpieces that was recognized in
in his lifetime um so you know it really
depends on the artist in the work
but usually they're they're really great
master works
they were recognized in their lifetime
as a masterwork they spent you know
years on them
um very different than like a napkin
drawing that he might
he might otherwise do that that makes
sense
uh what's been the most shocking thing
you've seen in the nft so far
right cause i know you're paying
attention i know you're trying to kind
of figure it out alongside the rest of
us but just
uh coming from the art world like what's
been the most egregious shocking thing
well i think i think the most shocking
thing is actually is actually positive
right like we
we were super skeptics in the in the
very beginning of this
i mean i i was 100 convinced that the
christie sale was just fabricated so the
most
the most shocking thing to me was to
find out that it wasn't
um so yeah i mean we're we're kind of
coming full
full circle um with nfts and i
you know i do i think a lot of these
technologies you know
independent of art and have been
starting technology companies for 20
years my passion you know before art is
really tech
and i think a lot of these technologies
tend to kind of emerge
have a lot of hype attract a lot of
early adopters
die off for five or ten years then all
of a sudden there's a resurgence
and you know there starts to become
mainstream adoption so i do think
that could be the case here right like
we could be in the ultra hype phase
which is bringing in a lot of early
adopters startups will will start they
will raise
they'll raise money they'll build
products around nfts et cetera
and then 10 years from now or 15 years
from now you start to get mainstream
mainstream adoption
um but yeah i mean i i i we've we've
just been
we've been surprised with with this in
general i think
for sure uh and then talk to me a little
bit about kind of what's been going on
the masterworks uh platform itself in
terms of the traditional art
uh have you seen um specific pieces that
people are really interested in
or anything you guys have purchased
recently uh that kind of stood out
i mean our you know our business is just
exploding so last year we raised over a
hundred million dollars you know this
year
you know we're on track to raise three
or four hundred million maybe maybe more
um there is there is huge interest in
general i think just because
most investors have have totally exited
fixed income
they're sitting on a bunch of cash
they're concerned about inflation
they're interested in real assets
generally but
but you know what what are real assets i
mean i guess real assets
are real estate that's not that
interesting from a return perspective
maybe collectibles
um but within collectibles art's kind of
ninety percent of the market right like
or it's
a 60 billion dollar year market so we're
seeing we're seeing
real interest from very sophisticated
investors
uh coming into these vehicles and we're
buying a 1 to 25 million
painting every every week now basically
um but it has it has been
very interesting to see allocators who
historically
are are regarded as some of the smartest
people in the alt space
buying directly into these vehicles for
for their own funds or
you know themselves it's also one of my
questions is how much of its retail
versus some of the institutional type
investors and it sounds like you guys
have really
kind of cracked into the institutional
world but also still have a lot of uh
retail usage
yeah i mean i i would say that today 95
is retail i think by the end of this
year
70 will be retail 60 will be retail like
we're you know we're seeing
we're seeing managed money broadly
speaking come coming into these vehicles
much faster than anticipated for all of
those reasons
yeah i'm waiting for the headline that
says masterworks
you know securitizes nft with steve co
steve cohen's participation right
some sort of uh of crazy headline of the
whole art world coming together
um what uh when you think through uh
kind of demographic wise are there
certain things that you see on
masterworks is it more
young people older people maybe
geography wise
uh certain areas that uh that people
come from
yeah i mean we're so you know we're a
regulated business so all of our
all of our offerings are filed with the
sec as public offerings
our sales team is regulated by finra
where marketing today is only only
within the us
so we're only marketing to u.s investors
that that doesn't mean that we don't
support international investors i think
15 of the investor base is international
now but we're not we're not really
reaching out to anyone outside of the us
um so the demand today that we have is
is primarily from
from u.s um in terms of demographics you
know it's really
it's really all over the map i mean i
you know we have people investing from
ira accounts
so generally they're older um you know
we have younger people
investing in these in these vehicles too
we're now having a lot more people like
when we started the business we weren't
really seeing people
who self-identified with the art market
who are collectors
investing in the vehicles we're starting
to to see that today
um so there's really not any any rhyme
or reason who's who's on the platform
we're kind of attracting everyone at
this point
yeah that's awesome uh and then last
question for you is
on the nft side uh is there anything
that you've seen outside of people
that's really kind of caught your
attention and you're spending a lot of
time on whether it's an artist
a specific type of uh sale or drop or
anything
i mean we we are i can't unfortunately
talk about anyone they're with a couple
of uh
well-known artists who want to keep it
quiet but i mean most of the activity
that we're getting are from
artists that we sell on the platform or
artists who we're friendly with
um that are interested in nfts they're
not sure
what to do i mean they see an artist you
know selling it selling a
digital work for 70 million dollars they
think you know that that could be me
um so we're we're trying to uh
i guess advise or potentially partner
with with those artists to
to help them kind of navigate the nft
space
figure it out that uh that makes a lot
of sense uh
have you bought any nfts do you want to
buy anything
i'm not smart enough to buy nfts
don't don't worry you you me and
everybody else i feel like
uh uh the one that gets me is uh nba top
shot
right it's like the art okay like you
know it's a digital version of the art
market but uh
owning the lebron layup from the you
know random game on wednesday
night in the third quarter uh that's the
one i probably don't understand
i know i kind of i i feel i feel like
for the first time ever i'm
like you and i are old i guess i don't
know i don't know when that happened but
it happened at some point
it's all right we'll uh we're gonna meet
up in our digital museums one day and
look at all of our digital art uh while
we have our
uh oculus is on and there's real art on
the walls and
we'll have the cognitive dissonance of
going back and forth between the two
can't can't wait for that awesome
listen where can we send people to find
you on the internet or find out more
about masterworks
yeah www.masterworks that i uh just uh
click request access mention that they
um
they they you know saw us on your show
and we'll help them skip the waitlist
and create an account
awesome man well listen thank you so
much we will uh we've done it once
before we will definitely do it again so
uh
just keep it up and i'm a big fan and
best of luck
thanks good to see you